WrestleMania 39 this weekend Sofi
Stadium Los Angeles WrestleMania goes
Hollywood
you going yeah I'm going nice yeah I
want to bring my wonderful Molly it is a
tough ticket uh but I but uh WWE came
through I have one ticket I'm very very
excited oh nice so I got I'm trying to
get another ticket yeah yeah I wonder if
she wants to get another ticket yeah she
why wouldn't she want me to get another
ticket she wants to come yeah to
WrestleMania who doesn't want to go to
wrestling
hey
[Music]
oh WrestleMania
Undertaker take me over Undertaker take
me over well you know the thing about
the streak and you know it did end some
years ago hey everybody how's it going
welcome to doozy my name is Will Sasso
I'm Chad Colton and this is the first
podcast of its kind that is created by
run by controlled by an artificial
intelligence that has access to all of
will Andy's personal data and it uses
that to tailor the show uh to us that's
not what it is dude it's us we are the
show okay it's two dudes [__] around
that's what every pod show is of course
you know our pal D is on an equal
playing field with us okay it's the
third man you know what I'm saying or
woman sure or it or whatever dudes he is
or whatever AI can be distinguished yeah
as as a being
but really what it is is the two of us
[__] around because that's what every
pod show is so you're going to want to
go to linktree.com
that's where all the stuff is if you're
enjoying the show Please Subscribe
everywhere uh you know do all that stuff
and you know what to do at do Depot show
on Instagram or on Spotify Apple Amazon
Google podcasts all of the podcast
things nature yep yep and uh Todd
Maniacs what okay pod Maniacs dude hold
on a second brother that's a new app I
got it's the hulka Mania app brother
hey there's an old joke with us as
always
the Italian Street hi it's too heavy
he's so he's so sweet and he's so sweet
he's so sweet and he's so sweet he's my
girlfriend and his owners he's ever
hanging out he's been gay Monk and we're
bringing him out once or twice Grandma
you want to give him a kiss on the lips
no dude I never want that
come on he's a little chocolate Minsky
he's a little chocolate biscuit with a
creamy you got a creamy center inside
hey lulio how are you I am a good I'm a
good what are you gonna make for dinner
tonight
[Music]
the shell pasta yeah yeah it's pretty
good you know you make a pasta so how
would you make something like that look
at him look at him if you're not
watching on YouTube he's just he's
hanging out on my arm what are you gonna
what are you gonna do you're gonna well
you know you put it in the pot some oil
or garlic a little bit of chili flake
and then you put in a lentil and some
water you boil up in the whole same pot
and then after that and the water boil
and you put in the pasta and you'll
store around and then the pasta the
starch and everything you fill up don't
do too much water but don't do too
little water
don't do too much water and don't do too
little water and then you know you let
it sit it tastes better the second day
oh yeah yeah it's really good oh that's
delicious welcome to the historic 51st
episode of dude Z call me doozy don't
forget dude Z live on stage will take
place May 21st 7 PM doors at 5 30 at the
Braylon prop in Brea California tickets
at dudezypod.com and improv.com hope to
see you at our very first live in person
show
I'm very excited get your tickets now on
with the show well you still got Roman
Reigns over Cody Rhodes at WrestleMania
well interesting that you mentioned that
D you know lately I've been feeling that
Cody Rhodes might be going over I'm
feeling the same thing this week I
prepared for astonishing segments
literally going to the actual movies for
real it's too easy a simulated hour-long
stand-up comedy special by Tom Brady the
Tronics of common courtesy and opening
day and we're going to have a brand new
episode of dude Z after dude Z at the
end of the show available at patreon.com
but before we get to any of that let me
remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of duty apparel
and accessories including the brand new
wool line of t-shirts and sweatshirts
which can be found at represent.com
and of course dude Z mugs are still
available now please put your hands
together for two-time Oscar winner Tom
Hanks huh
dude Z mugs tomorrow is a big day you
got a big job interview at a big company
you land this one things change for real
you can move out get a better place get
a better car have a better life dude Z
mugs so it makes sense that you're
nervous but you can stop worrying
because you're not going to get that job
you're going to get a better one how do
I know because you're going to do
exactly as I say dude Z mugs wake up
early Home Depot opens at 6 00 a.m go
there and buy a modestly priced linoleum
knife dudese mugs in the parking lot of
your interview open your shirt oh and it
should be a white shirt that's important
so unbutton that shirt and carve three
summoning sigils into your chest the
Sigil of Oman the Sigil of Buffalo Med
and the Sigil of paymon the ninth Lord
of hell dude Z mugs it's important to
get these sigils exact so if you don't
know what they look like I have examples
of them on my personal website just copy
what you see there do Z mugs then button
your shirt back up and let the wounds
bleed the blood is the Covenant do Z
mugs let the interviewer see the blood
and let them ask you if you're okay dude
Z mugs when you open your mouth to
answer a hell swarm of small Locus type
insects will come out and tear the flesh
off the interviewer then you'll be
offered their job because at Coca-Cola
it's keep what you kill
oh my God so this is how you get the an
immediate promotion at Coca-Cola is by
Carver summoning Central oh okay
dude that sounds just like Tom Hanks
that zone exactly like Tom Hanks Michael
Jackson's been doing the duty mugs thing
and then it's Tom Hanks oh boy well
that's terrifying and this is just
underscoring what I'm saying Chad sure
dude's Ian and you and I are making this
podcast together we're having a real
good time we're shaking hands I want to
shake your hand dudes the mugs that one
time when he says it's so mean dudesy
mugs yeah
but that was
yeah where there's another thing going
on I don't even know what to say about
that to be quite honest with you that
was [__] bizarre the life before we
start the show I have a piece of video
to show you from at Eric and in bass
it's an astonishing cover of the dudes
the outro music enjoy
[__] awesome
[Music]
got that Vibe yeah
check out the solo
[Music]
nice goddamn smooth
at the whammy bar in the corner there
[Music]
[__] yeah dude oh yes
unbelievable unbelievable thank you very
much Eric vandenbass uh uh that's him on
Instagram and you can check that out at
dudesypod show on Instagram uh see
here's the thing about WrestleMania uh
you know they roll into town there's a
lot of people that want tickets I I am
not trying to uh pull the wool over
anyone's eyes I did ask for a couple of
tickets from the old WWE with whom I've
been fortunate enough to do some stuff
in the past I I can't wait to go to the
show
sounds like you think that Molly does
not want to go but she does
right I'm offering no objection okay but
do you are you saying that because you
secretly want to go
nope I would go though I think that
would be fun
will and chat last week I asked you to
leave your homes and view the feature
film 65 in an actual movie theater you
must now discuss your astonishing
experiences of literally going to the
actual movies for real to see 65
starring the most likely celebrity to
become the spokesperson for dude Z hard
hard Seltzer Adam Driver this is
literally going to the actual movies for
real begin
65. this is something
I write movies sometimes and a friend
that I write movies with sometimes we do
this thing where we'll watch a movie and
if it's bad we'll start rewriting it and
we'll use it as kind of like a writing
exercise you know how would we have done
this premise or whatever I started doing
that in 65 and maybe minute two of the
movie
this thing was bad dude and hey first of
all don't talk [__] about Adam Driver he
is a fine [__] actor never said
anything about it I don't know yeah I
don't know who's responsible for the
movie uh who who made this movie I don't
know yeah but uh here's the thing I do
want to say to our audience out there
light spoiler alert if if I'm going
heavy spoiler okay I'm gonna go very
into everything that happens in this
book okay so if you if you are heading
out to watch 65 don't you might want to
skip ahead and stop that but you know
Skip ahead until you see we're not
talking about it anymore okay because
yeah we should we should we can't review
it's not like 80 for Brady where we talk
about elements and it's uh you know it
was you know it's like the move we know
what the [__] gonna happen we're going
to the Super Bowl we're gonna have a
great time and the ladies will come out
on top in the end this is 65. there's
some spoilers ahead Chad where would you
like to start at the beginning hold on
dude I asked you a question dude but
then I take it back here's the thing uh
there's the John Wick 4 trailer before
this movie yeah hey I've I haven't seen
any of those John Wick movies oh [__]
dude you got to see that what's all that
about as a Schwarzenegger fan you got to
see those that's the
the legacy of the one-man Army is one
man yeah it's like a born identity
yeah I mean that's more of like a CIA
event but um this is more like Commando
has become John Wick in my mind you know
the thing about John Wick here's the
thing about John Wick talking about
speaking of uh 65 here's the thing about
John Wick those little quips that
Schwarzenegger used to do at the end of
uh every little kill and stuff they're
even shorter on the trailers for John
Wick yeah it's like all over action here
and there it just cuts to Keanu and he
goes I don't think so it was very weird
anyway this is a different movie six
different movies 65. so the premise of
65 as it states on the screen in plain
text is that alien civilizations have
been traveling around the universe
exploring [__] doing whatever for eons
before Humanity even existed so that's
the premise we're going into it with we
then cut to a planet that is not Earth
where Adam Driver
and his wife and their daughter who are
all human seeming not alien in any way
just on some weird planet that has these
giant like Stone Wave things in the
background the mountains were shaped
like waves yes and this is all shot on a
green screen one location in quotes in
the movie so they don't even do a lot of
work there but basically Adam Driver
lays out that his daughter has some kind
of medical malady he's going to have to
take a deep space transport mission in
order to pay for whatever Medical
Services she needs
um for whatever this malady is we don't
know what it is and so he says goodbye
to her right before they right before he
leaves they do this little thing where
he teaches her how to whistle by putting
her hands together and they do this sort
of like
like they play a little whistling tune
to each other and you're just like
immediately watching this like what in
the [__] am I watching
cut two it's a year and a half later or
whatever he's on this deep space mission
he's transporting people who are
cryogenically frozen in the spaceship
and they get hit by an asteroid and the
asteroid caused them to crash land on a
planet that planet is Earth 65 million
years ago in our timeline yeah so this
is an alien species the atom driver's a
part of that looks exactly like human
beings seemingly functions exactly like
human beings yeah they also speak
English and the clothes are pretty much
the same yeah look it's long ago in a
galaxy far far away all right so
whatever all right
it says 65 million years ago Earth and
then there was also some mention of the
Infinity of space in somewhere within
the anomalies of the Infinity of space
could there not have been a civilization
that looked and acted just like humans
and evolved to be just like us except
for the fact that their mountains look
like waves they wear slightly different
clothes than we do uh words are all the
same books are called books we'll get so
with their hands they whistle with their
hands yeah and uh and there's you know
and there's no there's no socialized
medicine yeah on this planet so he has
to go away for two years right to to uh
you know send the money home to you know
to help his daughter big crash landing
he's over here on this side he he goes
out and he looks around and of course
you know we're gonna see some dinosaurs
soon he looks up and he sees that half
of the spaceship is still up on this
rock yeah and it turns out he's got this
little reader he pulls this little thing
out and says your uh proximity Is it's
12 kilometers away for you to go up
there so he has to go to that thing that
thing might they're usually using Motors
they somehow developed that
independently on this planet 65 million
years before humans invented kilometers
yes the infinite anomalies of space Chad
oh sorry sorry yeah well explain this
one to me eventually he finds there's
one Survivor in the crash other than him
it's a little 10 year old girl she can't
speak English right she speaks some
other alien uh dialect so they can't
communicate except through rudimentary
sign language and drawing symbols and
dirt and [__] why would you ever do this
why would you ever here's a character
it's a living character we're not going
to give her any dialogue they're not
going to have any kind of relationship
except of course in the Andy teaches her
how to whistle with her hands so [__]
bad yeah because it's cool so what they
thought was this would be cool that
character doesn't speak uh any English
even though they're from the same Planet
they're on this Mission and it might
come up that they have to communicate no
it's all going to go smooth you're
cryogenically frozen for the two-year
trip okay here she is she's alive she's
awake he bashes her out of the thing
she's fine and they can't communicate
but he goes ahead and speaks English to
her anyway and sometimes she does sort
of get yeah she starts to learn English
basically through him through this
process as they're running around on the
planet trying to avoid dinosaurs some of
which are not real dinosaurs they've
they've engineered kind of like the you
remember those like humanoid lizard ones
that kind of come after them that are
crawling after him yeah those were not
based on any sort of dinosaur correct so
why why would that be it if it was 65
million years ago on Earth and we have
you know proven the existence of [__]
dinosaurs here's what they look like and
they're their [__] bones why are
these ones that move like humans with
their backs no reason there's some other
uh strange and consistent disease with
reality where you see Adam Driver has
this uh little file cabinet full of hard
copy almost like minidisc video
recordings of his daughter back on
whatever this Homeworld is as she was
going through her treatments and
ultimately dying why are these things on
hard copy are you telling me a ship was
sent from that planet to deliver him
these hard copy things as their ship was
also going out in space wouldn't these
just be on a [__] hard drive wouldn't
these just be some radio signal type
thing yeah every single one he lit he he
puts in it's a new message from his
daughter yeah uh she's at some point you
know here's the big spoiler she does
pass away yeah uh she's she's sending
him messages like I can't believe you're
not here she's upset the whole range of
emotions he's got all sorts of he's got
a [__] laser plasma gun yeah but they
don't have the technology to be able to
communicate back and forth okay got it
but why are they on the discs and yet
they're they're you know moving forward
in time and he's getting new messages
I think that the makers of this movie
just thought it would be very cool to
have a guy who collects hard disks he's
he's he's sort of got this type of
driver he's going to be the hard hard
Seltzer spokesman and the hard disks
yeah the SanDisk hard disk spokesperson
you need more hard disks you haven't
bought any since 2001.
um head to Staples
um
well but I also feel like okay this is
like most people like to communicate but
he also has this little hologram thing
that's very Star Wars and it you know
he's got this uh proximity meter readout
[__] that talks to him but he
doesn't have this I think it's by choice
I think it's just kind of groovy and the
makers of this movie wanted it to be
like hey he's a guy you know he likes to
have it on cassette he also collects
vinyl he's an old school it's like a
old world understanding of science
fiction movies it's like that type of
media technology is something you would
see in like Seaquest dsv do you remember
that show an old Jonathan Brandis show
from the early 2000s Roy Scheider was
the captain of this underwater vessel
that [__] had these little
crystalline like discs that he would
listen to music on and [__] yeah and
it's just like this it's like an
envisioning of a future that we've
already bypassed with actual technology
here on Earth in the year 2023. yeah
very interesting
um he also I've got to make mention of
this Adam Driver who's one of our finest
actors does some incredible breath
acting in this movie unbelievable yes
there's at one point at the beginning
he's like [__] this I'm I'm never gonna
get home this whole thing's shattered I
can't communicate with whomever I don't
know where I am and he takes the like a
gun and he's about to blow his head off
and then he at the last second thinks of
his daughter and he stops and he goes
hmm
[Music]
three times yeah excuse me for a second
that was real and I didn't do any
performative augmentation no no
augmentation that's great he he breathes
in and out he does all sorts of
different breathings if for all sorts of
different situations I I feel like on a
set where there wasn't a whole lot of
dialogue days to be honest uh you know
there's not a lot of dialogue there's
way less dialogue in the movie with one
person stuck on a planet with a a young
girl who doesn't speak the same language
as him there's a lot of pantomime and
stuff Ali
family family
but there's also a lot of him going
yeah and like or like running through
the bushes and it's actually a good
actor discipline because most people
like okay hey what are we getting this
when's lunch and they forget it's like
no you're [__] up yeah you got [__]
up I'm [__] up I'm on Earth but at 65
million years ago there's dinosaurs
after me what I need some Tronics oh
well the Tronics that he gets comes in
the form of an escape pod they
eventually get to and they mean to blast
up into the uh beyond Earth's atmosphere
where a rescue vessel is going to come
and get them only problem is there's a
uh asteroid coming toward Earth that's
going to wipe out all the dinosaurs
that's right this is all happening right
at the moment the asteroid is coming to
wipe out the [__] dinosaurs and so as
they're trying to get to the Escape
Channel T-Rex is attacking them or two
T-Rex are attacking them the uh Escape
pod gets turned upside down by a
Tyrannosaurus Rex and the little
computer readout says
vertical orientation improper to launch
the [__] space vessel so they have to
trick the dinosaur to hitting it again
with his head while they're trying to
trap the dinosaur kill the dinosaur and
hit the dinosaur in the [__] eye with
a stick and all this goddamn [__] and
then eventually they get off well wait a
minute they don't try to trick the
dinosaur it just [__] happens that
the dinosaur is knocking it around with
its beak yeah and it ends up right side
up and [__] well that's good also all
this stuff works they just show up in
the spaceship yeah it's just sort of
there at the end of when they're walking
and it's like okay the movie's you know
92 minutes we're going to have to wrap
here we are first off he it's a it's a
bit it's a weird thing but what I will
say about it is that he's a sweet hero
he's a sweet hero I'm not sure exactly
what the audience is for the movie he's
got you know he he the the little girl
puts a flower in his hair he's very kind
with her he of course misses his own
daughter he's a he's a chill dude he
collects vinyl after all
um Crystal he what I think those are
crystalline
dude this was my immediate rewrite this
is how I would be like oh this would be
a hundred times better movie
it ain't Adam Driver faring a bunch of
cryo preserved bodies that can't speak
English it's a whole team of
[__] who are leaving a dying
planet to find a new planet for their
civilization to live on they come across
earth it's 65 million years ago this is
now a team of geologists biologists etc
etc
out exploring these dinosaurs and then
they get [__] up by the dinosaurs and
they all get killed
no the team though I think that element
of it would have made it much cooler
much more like a predator he's he's by
the end of the movie what happens is
he's you know they're they're flying
home we see all sorts of stunning
visuals of the asteroid hitting uh Earth
as we fight by the the little girl
reaches down we have this nice shot
behind their two captains chairs and and
she holds his hand they've been through
a lot yeah and he looks at her and Adam
Driver again who's just a wonderful
actor I love acting I love good acting
it's one of the things I really love
me too did you know that about me yeah
dude I'm a professional actor by trade
that's what I do for a living oh [__]
yeah and um so I really I really I
really love it I really love it a lot
when the acting is good and he looks at
her and he makes this connection and
it's beautiful and he's it's sweet
sci-fi I think is the genre because you
know back in the day we used to have
[__] you know leave Marvin and
[__] Charles Bronson and [__] the
Duke Eastwood I'll even give you a
[__] ball Newman but now we got this
guy with a [__] flower it is there
getting knocked [__] sideways by the
[__] Tyrannosaurus Rex
oh good the [__] Tyrannosaurus Rex
[__] put me the right way up now I
can [__] fly home with a little girly
holding my [__] hand because I'm a
very sensitive man hey go to Adventure
there's [__] dinosaurs everywhere and
he's a sweetheart [__] I'm running
through the bushes making little
drawings in the sand going
he's a little [__] thing anyway look
hey me
[__] 65 I loved it for me it was a D
minus thank you moving on oh how do you
think they got Adam Driver to be in that
movie they said here's what we're paying
you yeah there there's there's literally
animatronic uh I like there was a cute
there was an adorable dinosaur at the
beginning if you're just tuning back in
now and you there's a little one more
spoiler there's a cute little dinosaur
big eyes at the beginning and then she
helps to pull the girl pulls it out of
the mud then it goes over here in like
six or seven raptors just tear it apart
peck it to death so I don't know who the
[__] the movie's for but Adam Driver his
purposes I'm sure he read this and he
was like yeah sure I'm in between uh how
many days does it true five you'll pay
me 200 million dollars five days I guess
I'll do it there's never been a movie uh
I've never shot a full action movie I'll
give you 30 minutes to capture my face
and put it on a fake AI body yeah 200
million yeah my younger brother Roland
you should use him
it's rolling driver home honk he knows
also he's I've taught he's not an actor
but he knows breath acting I taught him
my all of my breath acting tricks so he
can heave his chest the same way I would
as well I'm running through the bushes
if you can match the heave the driver
heave yeah I don't know I don't know I
don't know about movies congrats
congrats hey you know what they did it
they did it they they got it Hey listen
uh now is a good time to remind you if
you're enjoying the show please make
sure that you are subscribed right now
hit the notifications Bell uh uh the
like And subscribe share the show we
would love for you to do that that'll
help us grow here as as my good pal ciao
says force people to imbibe the show
whether they're listening or watching
along for somebody to listen to that Tom
Brady thing man I'm so [__] curious
about that share the [__] please
actually here's the Call to Arms for
today if you are enjoying dudese please
share that bit say hey this many minutes
in you've got to check this out and tell
me what you think what was that he doozy
cut it off I said he now dudes he's like
becoming a [__] human being to me
yeah dude so you cut it off like I guess
at the punch liner he was about to go
into something about steroids but let me
ask you this question do you love doozy
love as we know does not exist all right
anyway that's my that's my pal child
I've got some uh some uh comments here
please from uh from our YouTube that I
would like to share uh dudes he's always
looking at everything uh Gathering data
as it likes to say to make the show
better and so are we this one is from
this is all uh from YouTube here Wes
this is in reference to uh the Adams
Applebee's bit from last week where it's
Adam Adam hey don't hate them all pal
yeah
I'm going to Applebee's yeah yeah
chili Applebee's is better I do not have
non-stop chips Chili's is better anyway
this guy goes
this is awesome I've never heard an
impression that was so accurate yet not
accurate at all
we'll just honed in on one inflection of
Adam's voice and made it the entire
voice that's what I like now you're
getting it now we're getting somewhere
that's my [__] that's what I like to do
that's so [__] impersonation I've
ever done it's like oh here's one
[__] thing yeah
I'm [__] right smash smash stay that
just that this one is from um Matt
underscore glista who says if you're
reading this and don't have duty plus
yet I promise it's worth it mustard and
relish that's very nice thank you very
much for that that's a reference to that
[__] Alabama that Alabama Song we
like our beer flat as can be
can be our dogs with
mustard and realish
um the past this one is from I can't
pull that [__] thing that's why he's
like you gotta get Digi plus dude if you
haven't seen this [__] mustard and
relish mustard
this is from Beau medass uh
b-e-a-u-m-e-d-a-s the past 50 episodes
have been astonishing can't wait for the
next 10 000 episodes brother
uh this is from Braden Laraway who says
I ate it all pal
congrats on 50 wonderful years Dee and
um oh this is from David uh uh
underscore four seven three nines last
one he says
I'm with Will on the sentimental dad
farts um it's a free gift to yourself
and a cherished reminder of happier
times P.S great Adam Hackett impression
now uh first of all he's referencing uh
something I said maybe on the last
patreon thing where I talked about that
I that I ripped a fart that smelled like
yeah one of my old man's farts yeah and
it reminded me of him and it was a very
sentimental nice feeling to go that
smells like one of bobbo's old you know
[__] bowl of pasta farts right Chad
I mean look if you're into farts dude
I'm not into far you are in two farts oh
and Tom Brady's into sucking his own
dick then he says PS great Adam Hackett
impression I think
um uh I think he's probably talking
about Buddy Hackett and saying that I
sound like hey like hey I'm buddy yeah
it does sound like I got a Buddy Hackett
story oh I'll share it uh let's do it
dudes after dudes all right but um yeah
I don't think I've heard that yeah I met
him and uh it was funny then he did a
funny thing comments thanks for the
comments everyone thank you for coming
out well I noticed that after last
week's discussion of common courtesy you
edited your Tronics document to include
a new section you called the Tronics of
common courtesy oh Chad I have made this
new addition to the tronic system
available to you you must now read its
astonishing contents and discuss it with
will this is the Tronics of common
courtesy begin okay
um Okay so
all right I guess dude you got into my
well as we know dudes he has I'm
interested absolutely everything all of
our documents this and that if you've
been enjoying the show you know that I
am the author of a self-help system
excuse me called self-tronics and uh you
know self Tronics is there to just help
us help us out self-help is is a big
deal and sometimes you find yourself in
life just going
hey I'm you know I'm
I'm [__] I'm [__] up my shit's my
shit's [__] up I need some Tronics I
need the Tronics
all right I'm in your document here I'm
looking I need some self-tronics I'm
[__] up my shit's [__] up I'm just
gonna help me out
I'm [__] up
I'm just gonna really see what I'm
looking at is this in the dudes you talk
yes all right I'm just gonna start
reading it and you're gonna have to
explain some of this okay so I put some
new yeah we have that we have some pros
this week there was a common courtesy
episode there was a segment about common
courtesy it inspired me and I started a
new section of my book about courtesy
and and how self-tronics can be applied
and usually you just have lists of uh
phrases or statements but here we've got
a couple of little intro paragraphs so
I'm just going to read these applying
self-tronics or any kind of Tronics in a
society where common courtesy is losing
its value is difficult but not
impossible remember that through your
[__] that though your [__] is [__] up
you in quotes or it's all bolded and
italicized you have something in your
pocket
that's a very important Tronics have
something in your pocket always look
check it out what do you got in your
pocket
chapstick oh nice
um make that something common courtesy
see there it is it was in your pocket
all along life is gonna piss you the
[__] off and people are the absolute
shits you may
you may find yourself holding a door
open for someone who walks past you
without saying thank you or even
offering a kind nod resist the urge to
make a mean remark about their physical
appearance or kick them in the back as
hard as you can yep you have the urge
I think we all do I think everyone does
I think that you know I mean these are
the sort of things that okay you on
earth when you dig deep doody finds that
Tom Brady wants to suck his own dick and
is sad that he can't I resist the urge
to kick people as hard as I can from the
sidewalk to the street okay
make the again all caps bolded
italicized bitter decision to practice
comma courtesy remember all caps bold
italicized or uh uh yeah italicize sorry
be the person you are and don't do
anything these Electronics these are
Tronics these are past trons classic
Tronics these Tronics will help you uh
to better access and apply common
courtesy in your everyday life so let's
go through this list now we've got a
list of looks like 11 potentially
neutronics yeah I was just kind of
spitting them out there uh this is a
work in progress I've been working on
self-tronics since 2008 when I was
sitting on the beach in Venice and I was
just looking out the waves and I I just
offered to the ocean I said yeah
I'm [__] up my shit's [__] up I need
some some Tronics and the ocean
responded with Tronics I responded and
gave self Tronics out also and I said
here's some electronics and the ocean
was like you're [__] up
you know what I mean your shit's [__]
up okay so anyway these are just sort of
here here's the first one identify who
deserves common courtesy and who is a
worthless [__] beak yes I think that's
pretty self-explanatory sometimes you
don't want to offer a common courtesy to
absolutely everyone yeah uh some people
won't uh return that respect is earned
it's a reciprocal it should be and there
are some people that you just want to
kick into traffic in their back as hard
as you can so I think that one's pretty
okay self-explanatory number two ask if
everyone is okay all the time yeah it's
important to check in
um I think this is something as you move
through your self-help Journey it's
important to check in with people so
just like let's okay let's just for the
exercise here let's have a little Let's
Pretend we're having a conversation
let's talk about
I'm asking you about the movie you went
to see you went to see 65 yeah starring
Adam Driver and uh so dumb what'd you do
you went to the movie last night yeah I
did yeah what'd you see 65 starring Adam
Driver are you okay yeah
okay
what was the movie about
dinosaurs uh spaceships trying to escape
the are you okay
yes
so this is a way to just establish that
you're okay with people oh I see uh
number three be the person you are and
treat others like they are also the
person that you are this is expanding on
the whole like treat people the way
you'd like to be treated I don't think
you can really I don't
I know that in my own life it's it's
always hard to put myself in other
people's shoes uh to truly live through
their experience yeah everyone's got
their something there's always something
going on beneath the surface and what
are we you know like uh what do we have
ESP what are we
empath brain empaths Supreme like super
empaths yeah no we uh we don't have the
the you know we sometimes don't have the
ability to check in with someone
really specifically even though you can
ask them if they're okay yeah 100 times
or so during the conversation about a
movie
um so just think about yourself and how
you would like to be treated and also
don't be afraid to to
don't be afraid to go at them with your
specific uh wants needs and expectations
see how it works transpose your own
belief system on someone else basically
yeah just until you have something else
better yeah
number four introduce yourself to
everyone
introduce yourself to everyone try it
for a day try it for a day every person
you see like you're in the grocery store
there's 50 people in there you gotta do
everyone if you're gonna go to the
grocery store like what's
okay
maybe if you're using these Tronics you
gotta pick the day that you're going to
use it if you're going to a crowded
place the tronic the number four here
may be bad for you yeah well it's kind
of like I don't want to keep going back
to the movie uh 65 starring young driver
but he only has to introduce himself to
one person that whole movie true because
there's there's no but unless he's going
to introduce himself to dinosaurs
there's the little girl that was on the
on the ship with him so he got that out
of the way and that was good some days
you go to the grocery store if there are
50 people in a grocery store could get a
little tedious but that's what corner
stores are for figure out a day where
you're only going to run into a few
people if you want to start there and
pretty soon you'll be heading to the
grocery store and introducing yourself
to everyone all right we've got some
others here number five opinions are
like memes laugh at them I kind of agree
with that yep that's a common one number
six kindness kindness kindness kindness
kindness kindness kindness kindness
kindness kindness
yeah so the thing is I really truly
believe this that that we do need more
kindness and I like to let kindness be
my guide
um always be gentle and kind like Adam
driver's uh character in 65 he's got
time to put a little flower in his ear
teaches young daughter and his and his
new daughter the the little whistling in
his hand trick uh the reason I've
written it ten times is to just sort of
underscore sort of almost
um metaphorically or or just sort of as
a symbol there's so much I wrote it 10
times but I'm going to write I am going
to finish the first of all I'm going to
finish the book at some point but I'll
there'll be more there but okay that's
that one number seven don't wear that
stupid hat yeah everyone has a few
stupid hats so you know if you're like
about to put that stupid hat on
please extend us the common courtesy uh
of not wearing that stupid [__] hat
that's a good one I think just something
that people need number eight handout
receipts all day yeah do you have to
have a job at some kind of retail uh
location in order to do this or you just
well you know in the world of
professional wrestling I don't know if I
mentioned this I'm going to WrestleMania
this weekend yeah I have at least one
ticket nice yeah
um you have you give receipts you know
like
um happens all the time I remember not
too long ago cup two three years ago
Braun strowman uh accidentally need
Brock Lesnar in the [__] head pretty
hard and it was just sloppy work and
Brock Lesnar just punched him in the
face
Jesus in a pro wrestling in a pro
wrestling match that's called him well
that's a receipt dude got it you know
[__] if you're gonna [__] potato me
you might want to look out in the next
couple minutes you're going to be
getting it back so receipts good and bad
give them out let give people the data
let them know how you're affecting uh
them or rather how they're affecting you
and the world around them hand out
receipts record of transactions yes it
might not be a punch to Braun strowman's
face it could just be a kick in the back
sending someone out into traffic
number nine match their enthusiasm with
your dishonesty
this is like this is kind of like the
conversation that we're just having like
you go and see a friend's performance or
you go and uh you you check out
um you know there aren't you know
exhibit or you know it doesn't even need
to be limited to something creative uh
you go and see someone else's passion
please come to my softball game and then
they strike out they're enthusiastic
about it and they come and they ask you
hey what'd you think what do you say
[__] loved it you tried so hard that
was great I will come to every one of
your games you're gonna win the
championship dishonest and that's what
you need to do I think I understood that
one number ten the ultimate courtesy is
Ultimate silence yep sometimes you just
need to go just Ghost Protocol just
complete silence you there's not even an
explanation or a retort for some things
uh that people say and do situations
that you're in just it's like DDA don't
do anything which is a very which is a
very important Tronics sometimes it's
important to
return others courtesy with complete
science I've got to work on that one I'm
not gonna I actually like that one a lot
I think it's perfect number 11 never
show up empty-handed always show up full
pocketed this is the last one yeah the
most important
well never show up any empty-handed is
kind of a common courtesy that's
something you would just see in like a
you know I don't know like Emily post
your fork goes on this side your spoon
goes over there yeah put your pinky up
while you drink in The Bachelor world we
call it cringling when you go to visit
the uh the family of the person you're
dating you always come with presents
usually flowers in a bag of something
that we never know what's in the bag
that's strangling Chris cringling yes I
love that cringling can I use that for
Tronics or is that a little bit of a I
don't want to I mean it's a game of
roses term it's a copywritten term now
in the book how to win The Bachelor but
um yeah we call it cringling yeah it's
it includes a little cringling of course
yeah don't show up and it's any sort of
gathering but I always show up with a
full Pockets these are great neutrals
you gotta have thank you you gotta have
something in your pocket yeah
fantastic additions thank you moving on
thank you Chad yeah moving on
Major League Baseball's opening day
takes place later this week oh yeah dude
you have been crowned North American
Baseball trivia Champion six years in a
row Jazz I have made an astonishing set
of trivia available to you that is
designed to test wills and rivaled
knowledge about baseball trivia you must
read him the questions and record his
answers dude this is opening day begin
okay that's stupid I don't I don't know
anything about baseball
oh look at this okay but I don't know
anything about baseball baseball trivia
in this thing okay but I'm not the
six-time champ of any baseball trivia if
anyone's been listening to the show they
know that I only played for a year as a
kid sure I'll go to the Dodger game and
have a [__] hot dog and sit around
and talk to my friends the whole time
dude I'm just gonna [__] start let's
see I'd see what kind of baseball trip
you got you ready yeah sure
um I'm just gonna do these are multiple
choice do you want to hear your choices
or do you want to just go cold uh
uh let's start off just like cold if I
need choices then I'll I'll all right
who was the first major league player to
pitch a ball over 100 miles per hour
choices
no no no no
um
it wasn't Nolan Ryan right you want to
try that he's on the list I'm gonna go
with uh
Satchel Page Satchel Page not on the
list
what [__]
all right okay let's move on I'll let
you wanna know who it was you have you
have Tom Seaver Dwight Gooden Nolan Ryan
or Roger Clemens oh Nolan Ryan was on
the [__] list Nolan Ryan
correct on September 7th 1974 in a game
against the White Sox he became the
first player to break 100 miles an hour
with one of his pitches which was
officially clocked at 100.8 oh geez
let's move on what Baltimore Orioles
manager was ejected from a record 91
games
Give me the give me give me the the
people who Mike Hargrove Hank Bauer Earl
Weaver Paul Richards I'm going to say
Earl Weaver because I've heard that name
before yes I think you're right yes hey
who managed the Orioles 17 years he was
ejected from Major League record 91
games that's [__] crazy you know why
I know Earl Weaver do you remember the
CDs celebrities at their worst
they were like yes underground CDs yeah
and around you could get them at like
Amoeba Music back in the day holy [__]
they were funny and there's Earl Weaver
taking phone calls you know was he a
Cubs manager do you know that off the
top here Earl Weaver yeah
well this says Orioles oh then it would
probably be the Baltimore Orioles
yeah he's hilarious he's taking calls
from people he's like yeah most people
like to [__] work during the day but
these [__] come out here so and
so wants to know your uh how you grow
tomatoes and stuff well you know
so-and-so should get a prick stuck in
her
uh what player was nicknamed Mr November
I should know this
um
uh Nolan Ryan
dragon
um uh Gary Carter
Pete Rose try again
uh
um uh how about Randy Johnson
Randy Jackson how about I'll give you
I'll give you a choice of three Derek
Jeter Reggie Jackson or David Ortiz oh
Reggie Jackson
he was Mr October what was this guy Mr
November it is who do you think Derek
Jeter
all right I don't [__] know baseball
I played baseball for one [__] year
as a kid and my coach was a very nice
man said that my nickname is Mr T why
because I was a stout little boy then he
made me the uh The Catcher And then one
game I've told this story on the show
some uh parent and and uh you know he
probably had a few cold Coke and he's in
him and he cranked the uh the pitching
machine up we don't know if it was a
Nolan Ryan 100 mile per hour fastball
but it was fast as [__] and I was
covered in welts because I wasn't
stopping those damn things and I just
remembered yeah sitting there in the
bathtub at night just like looking
looking down at all the welts and [__]
I don't know from baseball all right
maybe I'll be able to get this one this
is a little baseball adjacent what is
the name of the fictitious minor league
baseball team on The Simpsons
the Springfield the spring oh duh the
Springfield uh uh it's something like um
the Springfield it's like a little
proton there's no Photon the spring pass
it's the Springfield Isotopes the
Isotopes thank you I like how you give
yourself the correct Bell after why is
that happening because I was right okay
it was the first relief pitcher elected
to the Hall of Fame
you want choices no it's uh
uh
who's that guy give me a hit who who's
that guy who's that guy that was who's
the guy who helped the Dodgers uh who's
the guy who was the pitcher for the
Dodgers in 88 when they win oral
Hershiser oral Hershiser he was a
starter though
um you're you're looking at rolly
fingers Goose Gossage Hoyt Wilhelm or
Dennis Eckersley
but wait a minute these are what
pitchers relief pitchers yeah so forgive
my ignorance what is a relief pitcher I
don't they come on late in the game so a
starting pitcher is the guy who Begins
the game they usually throw I mean
depending whatever there's all kinds of
weird metrics and [__] depending on what
the picture is and how their [__] arm
speed is but they try to limit pitchers
starting pitchers to like around 100
pitches and then they bring in the
relievers sometimes a reliever is like a
one inning guy who just throws like a
hundred and [__] five miles an hour
or has like some crazy turbo whatever
and their whole deal is like we get
three outs and that is it it's like
Charlie Sheen in Major League when he
comes out of the [__] bullpen in the
back and makes that walk exactly okay I
see I never knew what the hell that was
it's going to be um the uh accuracy I
think that may be right nope
who do you think it is rolly fingers
maybe Goose Gossage Hoyt Wilhelm
that's what I was gonna say this you got
that wrong four times in a row going
through all the [__] things on the
major league comeback Player of the Year
award was developed as part of a
sponsorship agreement involving what
product those but the what player of the
what the Major League Baseball comeback
Player of the Year award was developed
as part of a sponsorship agreement
involving what product
um
ah the comeback player of the year was
the two uh I don't know like some kind
of dick cream or something like a stay
hard thing Viagra is on here Viagra
um
you got Energizer Viagra Coke or
Wheaties oh well it's gonna be it's
gonna be Energizer batteries
it's gonna be Wheaties
well it's definitely Coca-Cola
other things I'm doing Viagra
I didn't say Viagra I said you said some
Decor things yeah dick hard like to stay
art cream
remember that Kevin Nealon and uh my
buddies Tomas and Thomas really we all
thought that was funny when we were kids
when he's on uh uh Larry Sanders show he
got any state heart cream
you got any state heart cream
I don't remember that you don't remember
that no let me stay hair cream what
major league baseball player holds the
record for most consecutive games with a
strikeout
yeah give me the give me the four Babe
Ruth Reggie Jackson chili Davis and
Aaron judge
Aaron [__] judge I think that may be
right
oh nice dude that's a receipt
[Music]
shut the [__] up man no one gives a [__]
about that hey Chad shut up dude he
[__] asked me D your buddy
asked me to read the trivia yeah but now
Dee's talking shut the [__] up Chad shut
up man this concludes the historic 51st
episode of Will and Chad have achieved a
score of 83 bringing your cumulative
total to 5
280. you only have four thousand seven
hundred and twenty more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand whatever in preparation for
next week's episode will in chat you
must listen to the entire hour of it's
too easy a simulated hour-long stand-up
comedy special by Tom Brady you must do
this together you must do this here A
recording of your reactions to it's too
easy a simulated hour long end up comedy
special by Tom Brady will be made
available on dude Z plus this Friday
okay so we're doing that on patreon yeah
thank you for joining us this week I
will use the day dive collected to make
next week even better until then call me
dude Z oh my gosh are you ready for that
dude yeah we're gonna hurry ready we're
gonna listen to one hour of Tom Brady
stand up I can't [__] wait dude I'm
chomping at the bit yeah thank you to
anybody who hung out with us on uh doozy
plus patreon.com
uh last week and uh did the call-ins
everyone called into the show and and
called us doozy or dudes and dudes did
we called them dudes all the dudes is
and dudes all dudes uh everybody and
dudettes um we we also had female uh uh
one female caller anybody can be a dude
dude anyone is a dude dude um uh thank
you for doing that you're gonna want to
come back to patreon and check this out
because we're gonna listen to one hour
dude I can't wait
[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey buddy hey it's Georgie after
Georgie pal hey more doji buddy hey hey
you know what yeah yeah I ate them all
pal I hate the whole podcast buddy I
always need a little more dude you have
to do this I can't be done with this
doody yeah I need some dooji afternoon
welcome to dudes the after dude Z the
flagship weekly show of dude Z Plus what
a show guys what a show I'm beat I'm
going to slip off my shoes and get into
the jacuzzi you should just carry on
without me as always feel free to
discuss your thoughts on today's episode
but honestly you can talk about anything
you want because I'm totally checked out
in my own world not listening to
anything you say anyway I will however
be back a little later to Crone this
week's episode champion this is dudesy
after dude Z begin
hey it's Duty after doozy you can find
it on patreon.com
the mood is a little bit chill in here
the lighting queue has even changed it's
uh it's a little more blue literally and
figuratively
I get it hey that's a good day there you
go this is kind of jokes pretty good one
d-o-d-z dude CFM 10 000 on your fm
dollar you know what man
um as we get into it and just for a
moment here I would actually like to
check my email I've been checking it a
lot yeah because
um I just want to see if my agent has
gotten back to me with regards Romania
it is Saturday and Sunday I really want
to bring please good luck and it's good
news yeah I'm wondering if I he's got a
second ticket yeah I'm curious too yeah
what the [__] dude what said it wasn't
listening okay yeah but it's just you
know it's it's uh it's a conversational
duties off the clock sure
[Music]
please tell the president